[Music]
let me tell you a huge mistake people
are going to make though right now yeah
they can jump from one job to another
with the exact same skill set
doing the exact same thing
and make a lot more money than they're
making now yep and that's why a lot of
people are moving right now because
there's a serious
labor
crisis
in america and so
people companies are paying unbelievable
money to bribe you to get you to leave
now here's where the mistake can happen
you do it only for the money and you
move from miserable to well-paid
miserable
yep yeah and then you start worrying
about oh am i a job hopper and i get
that call all the time i took the i took
the raise and i took the influence i got
a bump i'm not worried about that i'm
just telling you you're looking for
happiness in the wrong place when you're
looking at a paycheck yeah i want you to
make more money there's no sin in making
money go make some more money that's a
good thing but also don't be miserable
if you're miserable now and you get to
do more of miserable you're going to be
more miserable 100
the high of the promotion and the bigger
paycheck wears off pretty quick yeah
like 35 seconds yeah and so you're
exactly right that is the wrong way to
look at it you've got to love the work
and you've got to be connected to the
results that's passion and mission it's
not enough just to have a talent job and
so that's why we wrote the book we want
people to have income that they want
make it and then also the impact from
paycheck to purpose purpose yeah it's
the second part of the title hello
yeah find something where you love what
you're doing not a hundred percent of
the time where you love the people but
not a hundred percent of the time if you
love a hundred percent of the time
you're just whacked you're a psychopath
okay there's some days it just sucks to
go to work okay i don't care how much
you love what you do i love what i do
there's sometimes i don't want to come
down here not much but if it gets to be
a lot y'all are in trouble because i
ain't coming anymore but the uh uh but
you know so you want to find something
you where you love what you do but that
doesn't mean every day is unicorns and
skittles
and rainbows that's not what it is and
for that matter dave you know we get
this question a lot how much of my day
can should be in my sweet spot now you
know 75 is a good rule of thumb but
bottom line is we all have to do stuff
that we don't want to do and to your
point there are some really sucky days
count on but
being shoveling manure yeah yeah but
it's it's passion for the work love of
the work itself it's a missional
connection to the results that brings
you back
and by the way we'll take care of all
the promotions that you ever need i mean
when you're on fire you got the juice
people see that in your eyes and they
look at you and they go this person was
born for this you're never gonna have to
worry about being promoted and you're
not gonna get to the end of your life
more importantly look back with a bunch
of regret you're gonna say you know what
i lived well
i'll never forget a buddy of mine that
was a career coach
another generation that does what you do
uh dan miller
i remember him coaching a guy one-on-one
who was a heart surgeon
and had his dad was a heart surgeon and
he was making like 450 000 a year
and um he was so
miserable he had become addicted to
heroin wow he was shooting it into his
ankles
trying to find a vein that couldn't be
detected as a dock right any but he was
just so he you know because he became a
doctor only because his dad was yeah and
he hated every minute of it so it does
not matter how much money you make
if you're miserable and you just make
more money just more well you're well
financed miserable that's all it is and
so don't do that from paycheck to
purpose again not not we're going to be
adults and say everything is not perfect
anywhere but at least find something for
god's sakes that you care about that
your is your why it fits into who you
are what you're passionate about and
that's what ken's whole life is about is
about connecting you to that from
paycheck to purpose the clear path to
doing work you love it's only 20 and you
get over 100 worth of free bonus items
at ramseysolutions.com